hi I'm Martin this is s'mores and we're
going to deploy a view app to Google
Cloud you will see every step along the
way so you can do the same and deploy
your app anyone on the internet will be
able to use your app and you won't have
to manage any servers let's get
[Music]
started the first step is to create a
view app then I'll create a serers side
app using Express and that will serve
the view app to users and provide an API
so the app can get data from the server
and finally we will deploy the app to
Google Cloud right s'mores yes all right
first off uh I need node.js installed on
my computer I already do but if you
don't go here to get it oh oh there you
want to get down okay I'll continue by
myself next I will run npm create View
at latest to create a default view
project it will ask me for a project
name it will also ask me for a bunch of
settings for the new project uh I'll
pick what I usually use
here it will run for a little
bit and then we'll show me what to do
next uh I'll CD to the directory created
I'll install the dependencies like you
told me
to and run the app for my local
machine there is my view
app great the app is working right
s'mores all right let's make a small
change uh I will open the source
directory
then open app.
viw and I will edit this line
here and
save aha we see that it was
automatically reloaded in the browser
excellent we now have an environment for
local development with hot reload when
we update the code uh let's build the
app for distribution I'll press Q to get
back my command prompt then I'll run mpm
run build to build the app for
deployment here we see that some files
were created in the dist directory those
are the files that we'll deploy to the
cloud later
on all right that was step number one
now we're ready for step number two
we'll create a serverside nodejs app it
will do two things one it will send the
h HML CSS and JavaScript uh files from
the disc directory to the user's browser
so they can use the view app and two it
will provide a serers side API that our
view app can call any web app I've ever
built has called an API to access the
database or to run server side code to
create that server side app I'll go up
one directory from The View app then
I'll create a new nodejs
app
the server side app will use the Express
package for handling HTTP requests so
let's install that if you prefer another
package that's
fine then I will create the file
index.js this server side code will
initialize Express so it can respond to
incoming HTTP requests and handle Json
data then I will tell Express to serve
files from the dist directory as static
files and not try to run that code on
the server and remember that directory
uh has the HTML JavaScript and CSS files
that are view app built and then I'll
add code to start the express server so
it listens to incoming HTTP
requests let's add a serers side API
that our view app can call to get a list
of
pirates when the app hits this URL this
code will run on the server first it
will extract the ID from the
URL then it will look up the pirate that
has that ID if no pirate was found it
will return a 404 error to the view
up but if the pirate was found that
Pirate's record will be returned in Json
format now in the finished app uh this
get pirate function would probably look
up pirates in a database but just to get
off the ground quickly let's hardcode
some of my favorite Pirates
[Music]
here all right the sde code is done uh
let's run on my machine it's convenient
to have an mpm script for this so I'll
go to package.json for the Ser side
nodejs app and enter this start
command we can use this ourselves uh and
once we deploy this app to the cloud
Google will actually look for the start
command and run it on our behalf up on a
server I will also add type module here
so that import statements work the way
we expect them
to
all right let's run that start
command the server is running on this
port on my local machine uh let's go
there with the
browser very nice our serite app sent us
the built view app files so I'm now
running that app in my browser now let's
take a look at that API I will ask for a
pirate number three here/ API SL Pirates
SL
three and there it is in Json format the
API is ready to be used by our view
app but let's move on to the last step
the third step was to deploy this app to
Google
Cloud first let's create a project in
Google Cloud for our app I'll go to
console. cloud.google.com
then I'll click through here and here I
can click this button to create a new
project if this is my first project on
Google Cloud I will also need to set up
a billing we will use cloud run which is
serverless so it has no fixed monthly
cost it will only charge us when our app
is actively creating response to user's
HTTP request what does that mean well in
this chart our containers listening for
incoming HTTP requests for the entirety
of the dark gray bar at the top
the blue bars are requests the green
bars shows what we're getting build for
as you can see when no blue request is
being processed there's a gap in the
green billing bars we aren't charged for
those gaps in other words if our app
gets 1,000 requests per day and each
request takes one second to process we
will only be charged for 1,000 seconds
of CPU time that day not 24 hours of CPU
time
we may even be charged less than that
actually if some requests overlap like
the blue bars in the
graph the first 200,000 CPU seconds each
month are free with Cloud run there's
also a free tier for memory usage you
can find all the details about the free
tier and the cost if you go above the
free tier here on cloud runs pressing
page in practice this free tier means
that none of my development or testing
projects have cost me anything it's only
when I got serious production level
traffic that I've actually had to pay
for cloud run having said that uh for
the rest of the steps in this guy to
work uh you need to create a billing
account
here if this is your first Google Cloud
project you get a $300
credit all right now let's get ready to
deploy The View and node apps to Cloud
run uh that's done with the g-cloud
command line tool and here are the
installation
instructions I've installed that tool on
my machine already so I will first
authenticate with gcloud off login this
will give me access to my projects in
Google
Cloud we see here that the g-cloud tool
tells us that we should set our current
project that's a good idea looks like we
need our project's ID we can find that
here at the project homepage on console.
cloud.google.com
let's copy
that and then we'll use the g-cloud tool
to set our current
project
all right let's deploy our app to Cloud
run I'll enter gcloud run deploy and
what I would like the cloud run service
to be called I can have multiple Cloud
run services in my project the g-cloud
tool will ask me where the source code
is it's in the current directory so I
will hit
enter then it says that some apis will
need to be enabled uh to help with
security uh Google requires us to turn
on each API we want to use in our
project I will turn on those apis in my
project next I get to decide where in
the world this code will
run any internet user will be able to
access the app but it will be slightly
faster for users close to the location I
pick here us Central one sounds good to
me so I'll enter
30 now it asks me about unauthenticated
invocations of my app do I want my
application to be reachable by Anonymous
user users on the public internet I do
so I hit Y
again and now it's building and
deploying my app this will take a few
minutes so I'll uh refill my cup of
tea and I'm back the deployment
succeeded and here it shows me the URL
that our app is served from let's open
that in a browser look at that there is
our view app it's now on the public
internet ready for anyone to use let's
also make sure that the server side API
works I'll enter / API
pirate1 after the base
URL and there is the pirate record uh
both the client side view app and the
server side API work from the
cloud we have created a view app created
a server side nodejs app and deploy them
to Google Cloud for all the the world to
enjoy now there are a few more things
you'd need to make a good web app that's
ready for actual customers your domain
name a
database and user
authentication let's start with the
domain name the URL that cloudrunner for
us is fine for development and testing
but we'd probably want to use our own
domain name before we send real users to
our app let's go back to console.
cloud.google.com and our
project I'll click the hamburger menu
and scroll down to serverless and Cloud
run here is our Cloud run service and
any others we may create in the future
if I click the service I get this page
where I can view metrics set service
level objectives check the logs and many
other useful things but we want
Integrations
I'll add an integration and pick custom
domains here I'll enter my domain name
that I bought
previously enable some
apis this will set up a load balancer
that points to my cloud run service it
will also create a certificate so people
can use
https when accessing my
domain when the apis have been enabled
I'll click this submit button after a
few minutes it will show me the DNS
changes that I will need to make with my
DNS hosting
provider I did all this for my domain
and this is what it looks like when it's
done by the way uh this load balancer
will carry a fixed monthly cost of about
$20 all right that was the domain name
what about the
database well there are plenty of
choices in Google Cloud if you prefer
relational databases Cloud SQL is a
popular choice you can turn that on in
your project like this uh but there are
other SQL choices as well if you like no
SQL uh document databases you may want
to use fir store instead by the way I
love fir store because it's completely
serverless so it has no fixed monthly
cost and it comes with a free tier
also it has a client side API so clients
can access the database directly without
any service code if you wish to set it
up that
way finally many web applications need
to authenticate the users let's talk
about
that it takes a lot of work to build
login functionality yourself and it's
kind of dangerous too uh you might leave
a security hall open I know I've done
that in the past for some of my hobby
applications that's why I prefer using
Firebase authentication it lets users
log in with their existing accounts from
Google Facebook Apple Microsoft and
others or users can create a new account
specifically for your app with their
email and a password they pick Firebase
authentication takes care of all of that
for
you so there you have it the three steps
to publish your view app to the world
using Google cloud in my opinion the
best way to build an app is to focus on
your users and what they need don't
waste time on server maintenance
networking scalability and so on Google
knows how to run production web apps and
can take care of that for you that way
you can launch version 1.0 of your app
sooner and version 2.0 of your app will
be able to serve thousands or millions
of users because it runs on Google
infrastructure thank you for watching if
you have any questions please enter them
in the comments also let me know if
there are any other servess topics you'd
like to hear about in future episodes I
read every single comment and I can't
wait to see what you build until next
[Music]
time